[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to our podcast
and the series called High School
memories my name is Thea and I'll be
your host today so without further Ado
let's dive into today's episode and
embark on a great journey
together get ready to be engaged
entertained and inspired today's topic
will be about bully bu in
schools bullying it's a word we have all
heard but do we truly understand the
pain and fear it can inflict in our
children for too many young Souls School
becomes a Battleground instead of a
place of learning and growth and it's
time we break the silence confront the
issue and protect our future
Generations bullying takes many forms is
the tauns The Whispers the hurtful
comments that can cut deeper that any
physical wound is the pushing showing
and intimidation that leaves the lasting
scars on a child's Psych is the
exclusion the social isolation that can
be just as painful as any physical
attack our children the ones we cherish
and hope to flourish are often the
silent victims of bullying they suffer
in the shadows bearing the weight of
Shame and fear they hide their pain
behind Brave faces and they Retreat into
themselves hoping it will all go
away but in fact it doesn't go away and
it won't the torment continues often in
Secrets leaving these young Souls
feeling isolated helpless and broken the
consequences of bullying are profound
and they can last a
lifetime what happens to a child who is
bullied they may suffer from anxiety
depression low low self-esteem and in
the most heartbreaking cases they may
contemplate self harm or even suicide
the trauma inflicted during these
crucial years of development can shape
their future in unimaginable
ways we must acknowledge that we can no
longer turn a blind eye to this to this
epidemic we must educate ourselves our
children and our communities that about
the profound consequences of bullying
it's time to create a culture of empathy
compassion and
inclusion schools should
be uh San sanctuaries of learning growth
and friendship it's not just the
responsibility of teachers and
administrators it's a collective
responsibility of parents students and
communities to ensure our schools are
safe heavens for
all so let's unite in the fight against
bullying let's Empower our children
children to speak up reach out and find
solace in one another let's these
empathy kindness and understanding let's
hold those who preparate bullying and
accountable for their
actions together we can break the
silence surrounding bullying in schools
and together we can protect our
children's right to an education
free from fear and
torment now let's let's discuss about
bullying causes first lack of empathy
bullying can occur when individuals lack
of BU lack the ability to understand and
empathize with the feelings of others
the def deficiency in EMP empathy can
lead to harmful
Behavior social norms and peer pressure
in some cases students May engage in
bullying because they uh
precisive it is a way to gain social
status or fit in with a particular group
uh peer pressure can be a powerful
driver of bullying
behaviors third family en environment a
dysfunctional or abusive home
environment can contribute to to
bullying Behavior children who witness
aggression or are subjected uh to it at
home May imitate those behaviors at
school environmental factors the
environment in which individuals grow up
can contribute to bullying a culture
that tolerates or normalizes aggressive
behavior may make it or uh may make it
more likely for individuals to engage in
bullying
cyber bullying the rise of the internet
and social media has provided new
avenues for bu
bullying anonymity and distance can em
uh embolden individuals to engage in
harmful online
Behavior discrimination and pre
Prejudice bullying can be a
manifestation of prejudice
or discrimination based on factors such
as race gender sexual Orient
orientations religion or disability
these biases can lead to targeted uh
bullying
behaviors mental health issues some
bullies may have underlying mental
health issues such as conduct
disorders uh oppositional defined
disorders or antisocial ual personality
disorders which can contribute to
aggressive
behavior lack of education and awareness
in some cases individuals may not fully
understand the consequences of their
actions or may not be aware of the harm
caused by
bullying it's important to address
bullying through a multi face faced
approach that includes education
preventation and
intervention schools families and
communities communities can work
together to create environments that
discourage bullying and promote empathy
kindness and conflict resolution skills
so far we have talked about causes of
bullying now let's talk about how to
fight
bullying raise awareness educate
students teachers and parents about the
different forms of bullying and their
consequences promote empathy kindness
and respect as core values with the with
the school Education and Training offer
anti-b bullying programs workshops and
training for students teachers and
parents teach conflict resolutions and
Comm communication skills to help
students address conflicts
non-violently create a positive School
environment Foster School culture that
promotes inclusive inclusivity respect
and acceptance of diversity celebrate
differences of and encourage students to
uh appreciate each other
uniques
restorative justice Implement
restorative justice programs that bring
bullies and victims together to resolve
conflicts through dialogue and empathy
focus on repairing relationships and
address addressing the underlying issues
engage parents and Guardians keep
parents informed about anti-bullying
efforts and encourage them to be
involved in their child's school life
thank you so much for joining us in this
episode of high school memories it's
been an incredible journey and we are so
glad you came along for the ride until
next time thank you and take
care
[Music]